[Music]
jets receiver terrell pryor got together
with his former teammates on tuesday and
he had some good moments but he also had
some bad moments on the day took some
razzing from washington defense backs
had dj swearinger square up like he was
going to punch him made him flinch
but also far more important than what
any washington players think of him as
head coach todd bowles not happy with
terrell pryor for
talking about his injured ankle here's
bowls on pryor
tyrell doesn't need to be descriptive
man i feel he should keep his mouth shut
and leave the injuries to me
as a coach how do you handle it
i've already handled it
we've had a conversation we'll discuss
our own in-house things in-house
look i understand that coaches have
a desire to keep as much inver injury
information under wraps as possible the
idea is you don't want opponents to be
able to draw a target on specific body
parts so they can put a little sauce on
an injured area or otherwise test it
that's the way that i've heard it
described you want to test it that means
you're going to hit him in that spot and
see if they can continue to play
i still think that if a player has an
injury he should be allowed to talk
about it i i don't have a problem with
that and i have a problem with coaches
and organizations that try to muzzle
players because what happens is the
player's not playing well people are
like oh he just stinks
and he can't say no actually i'm injured
i remember there was a time when it was
antonio camardi with the chargers turned
out he had a fractured hip the whole
season but they told him not to talk
about it so you know it just looked like
he he couldn't play anymore and i just
think it puts the players in a tough
spot and if they choose to talk about
their injuries they should be allowed to
although what they should be allowed to
do and what they're actually allowed to
do are two very different things because
if the coach says it it goes statue got
a question yeah were you surprised that
todd bowles told him to basically shut
his mouth i mean that's just one of the
strongest reactions from bulls that
we've heard isn't it i think there's a
real dichotomy between the way todd
bowles is behind closed doors and the
way he is publicly and i think he's made
the strategic decision that he's never
going to show anything publicly but this
is a tough guy scrappy guy
and i don't think he's afraid to get in
a player's face if he needs to not in a
disrespectful way but i think that he
he will say what needs to be said within
the confines of a locker room or a
meeting room but he's not going to call
guys out publicly and this is the
closest we've seen him come to doing it
it makes it clear he's not happy with it
and my guess is guys were told
specifically don't do it and then pryor
did it anyway
why do you think pryor did
i
i i think that uh he wants people to
understand why there's a perception that
he's not the guy that we thought he was
going to be and i think that you know
last year was such a disappointment for
pryor
if we accept the fact that he was
injured that helps explain why this
trajectory he was on after that one year
in cleveland full time as a receiver had
such a great year i expected 1500 yards
last year what did he have 300 maybe
maybe not even 300 with washington all
right elsewhere in the afc east there
was a lot of chatter yesterday from tom
brady he did a weei interview and he
spoke to reporters while he was on radio
he was asked whether or not given all
this talk of dysfunction between brady
and coach bill belichick the two men are
still on the same page here's what tom
brady had to say
i think our priorities are you know the
same as they've always been and i think
that's why we get along so well is you
know we're here to win
and like i said it's been a very
professional environment that he's
created i think i'm very lucky
to you know be in that environment i
think he's the best coach that's ever
coached in the nfl
and uh
you know i feel very privileged to have
kind of been mentored by him for as long
as i have
look i mean that's what i would expect
tom brady to say there's still a clear
sense there's some sort of tension that
something's not right that something is
askew now is the time to put all that
aside and focus upon their mutual goal
of winning another championship and
that's the thing whatever differences
they may have what other dysfunction
could be looming and let's face it tom
brady is under contract for only one
more year beyond this season when they
adjusted his contract last week they did
not extend it
they just moved some money around they
added some incentives but they did not
commit to him beyond the year 2019
who knows what's going to happen you
know we assume that the patriots will
want him for as long as he wants to play
and i think that assumption comes in
large part from the fact that they moved
on from jimmy garoppolo and kept brady
but just because they kept brady and
traded garoppolo last year doesn't mean
that they're going to keep brady until
he's 45 maybe there's a point between
now and 45 where they decide hey tom
it's time for us to move in a new
direction the dolphins moving in a new
direction as it relates to defensive
tackle gabe wright he was cut because he
got into a fight with running back
kenyon drake drake didn't have a helmet
on
gabe wright threw an elbow at drake when
drake didn't have a helmet on
grazed drake with an elbow
that uh connected in his back
a source called it uncalled for of
course it is but here's the reality if
it was a key player do you really think
that the guy would have been cut if it
was ryan tannehill you think he's
getting cut if ryan tannehill goes after
kenyon drake
uh for making a mistake on the practice
field and throws an elbow at his head do
you really think that adam gase is going
to cut him so it's that standard that
always applies examples are made of the
scrubs excuses are made for the stars
gabe wright's on the wrong side of that
line so he does something he shouldn't
do and he is out the door we're going to
be out the door for just a few minutes
when we return some over unders as the
preseason continues and the regular
season approaches we'll be back with
more pro football talk live on nbc
sports radio and nbcsn right after this
you